story from an eight news now viewer
complaints over a 24-hour tattoo shop on
the Strip overcharging tourists so the
Better Business Bureau even gives the
business
rating with several reviews online
claiming the same thing Madison
Kimbrough spoke to some who say they
were victims of a scam she also went
right to the tattoo shop to get the
other side of the story Madison joins us
live
yeah the women I spoke to Beyond upset
over their experience at Vegas Inc
tattoo shop here on the Strip as they
went in for a simple tattoo but left
paying over 500 in the end
it was just
a bad experience and so every time I
look at it I kind of think about it like
I was I was crying in the tattoo shop
Mason Slater speaking with eight news
now about being grossly overcharged for
a tattoo she got here at Vegas Ink
Tattoo shop located on the Strip Mason
stating that she was initially told her
tattoo was going to be a hundred and
fifty dollars but once it came time to
pay that number changed to over five
hundred dollars family friend Adriana
Baker saying at no point were they told
up front how much it was going to be
they quote you 150 they don't tell you
it's by an inch or by what they just say
150
and the tattoo itself is not a 500
tattoo Adriana making a tick tock of her
less than fabulous experience and come
to find out they weren't alone as
reviews online have the same exact
complaints from customers about being
overcharged even the Better Business
Bureau giving Vegas Inc an F rating due
to the complaints they've received so we
went to the tattoo shop to get their
side of the story and while they are
aware of the negative reviews they say
it's part of their protocol to go over
pricing before tattooing anyone as the
high prices goes along with being
located on the Strip we start off by the
square inch and the minimum starts at a
hundred under that square inch if it
fits within that that's your hundred if
it starts to exceed that square inch
then you're gonna it's gonna go up in
price unfortunately we have an extremely
high rent so we have to have a certain
price standard I wish everybody could
see the hundreds of thousands of people
that come out of here with a good
experience
now as for Mason she wasn't able to get
her money back Vegas Inc has two
locations that's going to be at Miracle
Mile at Planet Hollywood that's one of
them reporting live Madison Kimbrough 8
news now so while the Better Business
Bureau gave the business an F rating the
non-profit organization does not have
the authority to shut down a business
since there's no evidence of them
violating any kind of Health standards